nos portraits de jeunes de la génération
20 ans dans les années 2020 avec
aujourd'hui tom grain d'animateur radio
un pire beau métier la meilleure
formation c'est sur le tas au micro
bénévolement pour lui c'est un service
civique à montbard chez nos camarades de
diversité fm il s'est confié à la bombe
à gueye et tiphaine cypher
c'est dur c'est dur
c'est dur d'avoir un temps en 2001 c'est
tout
bonjour je m'appelle tom baumann j'ai 23
ans je suis originaire de dijon
et je suis passionné de radio
diversité femme soutient la tournée
d'yves jamait elle se poursuit dans
toute la france yves jamait c'est une
passion que j'ai depuis au moins dix ans
déjà en fait c'est venu un tout bête
c'est le soir j'avais on savait les
petits les petits appareils on écoutait
la radio caché sous le lit et j'y suis
tombé sur la radio et je suis tombé fans
de ce métier là je trouvais ça génial
dire des choses à la radio
il passera dans notre grande et belle
région j'ai le grand plaisir de tous je
le connais depuis
2018 si je me trompe pas nous rater
aussi
et du coup voilà on l'a accueilli en
service civique il ya déjà quelques
années et c était le début de l'aventuré
pour l'huile qui sortait d'une école à
lyon petite école de
mais de radio et il avait besoin de
pratiquer régulièrement la radio la
radio on peut l'être de plusieurs
manières en stage en service civique
dans le cadre professionnel ou dans le
cadre bénévole
diversité fait une autre radio et post
seconde demande ou deux
là on a la liste de tous les morceaux
qui on diffuse voilà toute la journée
donc ça va du rap au rock à la pop
aurait guère on a également de la
chanson française beaucoup on diffuse
énormément de chansons françaises cédric
il travaille ici reçoit les cds
directement via les labels donc en fait
ils les écoutent un parent et du coup
après selon les goûts en fait musicaux
de chacun les programmes programme
quelques titres
[Musique]
j'ai déjà postulé dans d'autres radios
etc mais sans succès on m'a dit aussi
beaucoup de fois que j'étais trop jeune
d'autres croyez peut-être pas en moi une
cédric actionnant moi je suis ici je
très heureux voilà en ce moment du coup
j'attends j'attends de savoir si on
pouvait avoir un contrat plus long mais
en tout cas je suis formé pour être
animateur radio dans tous les cas
[Musique]
c'est lui
je n'influence pas à proprement parler
directement sur la programmation mais je
peux conseiller cédric de s'intéresser à
certains artistes qui sortent et en mots
général il écoute et on a des artistes
comme un aussi donc c'est pour ça qu'on
s'entend bien sûr certains artistes mes
artistes préférés ils sont super variés
inspirés indochine sur le long terme
parce que ça fait plus de dix ans que
les sujets est mon père
en fait avec la radio mon programme
énormément de choses n'en a pas le temps
d'écouter vraiment les musiques et je le
fais ici en fait j'écoute beaucoup de
chansons ici beaucoup de musique qu'est
ce que je fais également ben je m'occupe
du chien voilà
qui vient souvent ici sinon après c'est
les activités basiques d'un jeune de 20
ans et les séries de la musique la
console un petit peu ouais voilà
j'ai obtenu mon permis en pendant
l'année 2020 en fait pendant la crise
sanitaire que je puisse être un peu
libre pouvoir retrouver entre guillemets
la liberté à la sortie de la crise quoi
le permis c'est la liberté puis surtout
à 20 ans quoi à 20 ans mais on est en
plein dedans on est en plein on est en
train de se lancer pour pour les jeunes
en train selon le site le marché du
travail
30 ans 20 ans bas dans mon idéal de son
envie de vous dire à la tête d'une radio
et est toujours là dedans mais comme on
sait pas de quoi demain est fait je vais
pas vous dire et puisque sam est un
métier très compliqué d'accès d'auteur
ni dans la gauche
crise avec des lasers jean trajean
s'agit du corps
découverts